the least of which the least noticed of
which is depression I mean you've seen
the recent the recent events and it's so
sad it kills me one of every four people
you will in turn interact with in San
Francisco is clinically depressed
they're not talking about it right but
they're clinically that and these are
the people that actually found it in
their heart and found the resources to
go and get diagnosed to the point that
they're actually clinically diagnosed
the depressed there are so many that are
unhappy and we're all sucking it in and
saying well I'm fine right you know the
typical answer is like how are you today
and you go like I'm just fine right I
actually pause when someone asks me how
are you today I say let me think about
it
I actually feel quite calm a little a
bit you know worried about the
conversation and a little bit
sleep-deprived that kind of awareness is
a call for me to actually understand how
I feel right the problem is the
following one in every four is
clinically depressed in suicide is at an
all-time high
suicide in general is at an all-time
high and we're not even addressing the
problem right our planet's resources are
depleted they're more and more depleted
and we're not even addressing the
problem you wrote in your book our
tendency to to be driven towards a
negativity to have negative thoughts be
the ones there what is it the there
seventy percent and then 62 percent of
all words related to emotion are
negative are negative and then the way
that the way that you just described
culture and civilization there's a
there's a there's a plateau you write
about as well that I think is important
to highlight and there are so many
people depressed suicide there's a
plateau of income that you earn per year
about seventy thousand or so is this
plateau because then you can buy all the
necessities you need shelter food water
education health care and then after
that it's applied seventy thousand
dollars plateaus happiness
the the thought about the about for
example like Anthony Bourdain
something that I read that I really
wanted to share that I thought was
really important was it's not about what
you live but it's about how you live it
and that really resonates because if we
just choose that all these experiences
that we live however we how we live
these experiences with love of the
present moment and the love of of just
life then it changes a lot of the way
that we live in a lot of the way that
other people live